Yeah, welcome everybody do another zoom call anybody's new to our zoom calls you come in to the zoom call automatically muted
If you want to ask a question verbally you have to unmute yourself from way to please wait till we get to the end of the ones that we're submitted
But you can always chat in a question on the chat too
It used to be what if we're starting doing this
eight years ago
Sorry, there's a woodpecker
Everybody was very verbal you'll call everybody was verbally asking questions
Raise it upon three years ago and shifted to most everybody
chats in there
whatever you guys want to do
Okay, so remember announcements are going to be on the members on the page the members
site home page there is a new announcement for next week and we'll not be having a zoom call next week so
No zoom call next week of the out of town
I'll still be taking some appointments, but don't zoom call
There would be a good
spot to
zoom reception
So those who call next Wednesday, but I always look at the announcements of the homepage of the member site
I just took a screenshot of it right here
And I already made that change those in the next week. So all right. Let's get to our questions
First question why is endemia common with cancer?
So endemia
And remember there's multiple different types of endemia and I have a blog post on all those different types of endemia
There's higher deficiency endemia B12
Endemia B6
Efficiency of me endemia folate deficiency endemia
And the most common there's one that's actually called anemia of chronic disease that his
Well cancer falls into it, but it is an iron deficiency of
And there are certain characteristics of each one of those
Endemias, so when we look at anemia, we don't just look at your total red blood cell. We look at hematocritin, hemoglobin and
HCV you know a bunch of different factors in there when we look at your CBC with differential so
Why is it common with cancer? Because some cancers can double upired. That's another one reason
It's common with cancers if it's an abdominal cancer, you could have a bleeding issue that could cause it
So even if you don't have cancer, a bleeding issue is the first thing you want to look at it versus layered efficiency
But it's typically common with cancer because cancer can double upired and then when you give hired to a cancer patient
You want to always couple that with a lead with
Artimicid because artimicid tends to follow iron, so it'll actually be just drawing iron, drawing artimicid into the cancer. So
You want to be careful you don't want to just throw iron and a cancer patient because potentially you're basically
You know possibly feeding the cancer
By giving iron when iron has been doubled up by the cancer, so it makes sense to be careful
Um, but you get to this point where you write in a catch 22 where you have to treat the ademia
What a person has mild ademia with cancer
I typically do not jump right at giving iron
um
Because of the fact that
The cancer is already thoughtfully not that you don't want to just feed it
so
Next question
What's the main difference between the true right and the atelier robin
Again, I used to use the true right for years and years only which were right
And we switch to the atelier robin
We basically only sell the atelier robin
For those that have on this call or listening to this that will true right or like what
What's up there? I wanted to tell you robin too
Well, atelier robin didn't come out till last year, so we couldn't have received one
And atelier robin only started producing
Machines for us and a few other practitioners solely because of some of the changes that have to put you around so true right actually used
The
Board the frequency board that atelier robin made
So if you have an older true right
Technically is
Kind of an atelier robin. I mean the board is the atelier robin
It doesn't call the characteristics and beneficial character qualities
of the atelier robin p220
Um because
Patrick robin proved the board so much and tried to get Mike with Mike old true right to use his approved technology
And of course Mike was a business man and
regardless about making
Judgment calls on why Mike did what he did but he stumped with
What he used and then when true right was sold back to the half years ago the new owners
You know made some different business decisions
To not use the atelier robin board that used what made out of china
Um
And it's just and they made different decisions. I'm not saying good or bad or judging what they did but it
It made me question the integrity of the company integrity of the machine will be forward
And we started looking for alternatives and we better hold the Patrick robin to
He was creating this for us and other practitioners and it's just a far better machine with a lot better benefits
So the benefit of atelier robin is if you put it on a telescope it holds its frequency much better
Now I would say that the older true rights probably hold them the same
Um a friend of I tested it with an oscilloscope and
It's the newer true rights that had the issues
Um
But that was an objective test and then the benefits in the tiller robin is that you could run
Um the level of harmonic frequency and I talked about that a lot
I think that's hugely beneficial for killing pathogens and killing cancers
So I think it's a far superior machine at this point
Um, though I think the older true rights are still great machines and
Still obviously we have patients that have been using them for a decade more and still alive when they're supposed to be dead
You know a decade or more ago
So it works it worked for me that's what I used to overcome by cancer
It's just the newer the new machines are different and I lost faith with them
But I have always said
From the beginning and my practice, you know
Was always that patients come first I'm not loyal to a machine. I'm not loyal to
How much you could make to eat a certain therapy or how much you can make selling a machine or anything like that it's always
What would I use myself what would I sell you know my old family members
And if I wouldn't sell that to my old family members that I won't sell it to patients
I wouldn't recommend it to I won't recommend it to myself or to a family member. I would not recommend it to a patient
I just wait the Holy Spirit is too convicted. He wouldn't let me do that feud
You know crash and bird before he would let me do something
Okay, next question
I am I apparently am going through inflammation of past musculoskeletal injuries
As a side effect of radiation treatment for stage 4 lung
tumor
The last of 30
I'm assuming radiation treatments who see targeted low level
Ghost was June 10th
Radiation was accompanied by chemo during the 30 days as maintenance following the end of radiation treatment the good news is the tumor is greatly degraded
The bad news is that the area where I broke three rib heads
happened two years ago and a jointed sturdom
Which was not injured recently became inflamed that are sensitive to the touch
from this has
A touch sensitive to the touch pain from this has referred to back muscles and putting the erector muscles
And according to my deep tissue the son's therapist question couldn't my right cancer program be contributed to the inflammation
I see there is an inflammation program on the right list should I be doing there
So can your cancer program be contributing to the inflammation no no
Cancer program is going to be targeting the cancer could it cause some inflammation around that if there's cancer that exists there
There could be some inflammation around the cancer that would be an immune reaction around the cancer
It wouldn't cause musculoskeletal inflammation at all
Um
It's not uncommon that radiation linkers that's the problem with the radiation therapy
Although they can kill cancer it can linger in your system or emperor
So pulling that radiation out at this point you see your best interest I would highly recommend
um using the
Radiogen
Oliopact but our uh store for the radiation of Oliopact or both of them on the store
They're just only apathic drops that can target your body to help you detoxify them
Highly recommend that
Is there an inflammation program on the right that you could be using yes you could be using that as well
However, I would say that um while frequencies can help with radiation you have to use more metabolic approach to inflammation
So using holiopathy using anti-inflammatory flavonoids like a plant called inflammatory
or capillarest from um bionics
Either one of those have a lot of uh anti-inflammatory flavonoids
Um the inflammatory clear enzyme is probably
Tests usually stronger than capillarest on most people everything's a little bit different
But those um have flavonoids that curcumin the bus wellie and the sticky dental the
Resveratrol the rosemary the corset and
Uh those are the things that are going to help decrease inflammation
Um, so I would be taking fairly high doses of that there really isn't an upper limit
You can't really overdose on those things
Um, but you have to spread about through the day
They all are water soluble and they have a half-life that's fairly short of the room
Which is half-life or was the veratrol is only like five minutes. It's a surest half-life of getting nutrient that exists
So you have to be spreading that out through the day. That's your best advantage to them
Um, definitely when you do radiation to kill
Cancer cells you are weakening
Other cells as well
So if you had lusculoskeletal injury and fracture and old muscle injury tendon
Um ligamentus injury you're they're they're going to be weakened
Um, and you're going to be more susceptible to injury
Certainly rib carcassal cartilage issues are very common
Because your ribs are always moving every grad through take
Um, carcassal cartilage injuries take a long time to heal
um
Uh
So
You know, it sounds like you're doing deep tissue massage other things
Maybe beneficial as well
Um, you see cold hot cold um backs things like that will maybe helpful
Different therapies maybe helpful even um laser treatment
Um
Even it's a weird it is certainly on your back if you use electrical stem PEPF can be helpful as well
Next question best advice for bone marrow cancer in the spine that's increasing
So I believe the first of the last this question is uh similar to got breast cancer that's the testicized to the bone
So it's not bone marrow cancer so understand
If you have metastasis to the bone
It's um, it's the same cancer that is now
Set up home somewhere else in your body
So it's still breast cancer. That's what testicized to the bone. It's that bone cancer
Um, unless you've had a biopsy and you're showing a completely new type of cancer
We have some patients that have two different completely different types of cancer
But if it's metastasis it's the same cancer so prostate cancer that's metastasized the bone
It's actually prostate cells
That are growing in the bone and it's weakening the bone
Cancer that metastasized to bone is always
Lytic meaning that it's destructive to bone
So you end up weakening the bone and if it's a weight-barried bone like the spine or
The leg or the pelvis then you're you know, there's certain parts of the pelvis that are weight-barried
But uh, it's you risk fractured
So uh, you have to a through your best uh, all levels to kill the cancer in the bone
That's where radiation can have its shiny moment
To kill cancer in the bone because you could get more specific
Which I have radiation you're doing all the natural things that you can do that would kill the cancer
You know where the primary cancer was you're doing the same things to kill the metastasis
So there's other things that you would do to help prevent metastasis but once metastasis is already taken place
How do you kill the cancer that's in the bone?
Again back to the same thing that you're doing to kill the cancer in the primary site
Now what else could you do if there's body destruction?
Loss of bone density then you're looking at doing things um
To increase bone density
Which to me the the number one the literally the only supplement that I would recommend to increase bone density is the product called osteocane
osteo-k
Um as in vitamin K because it has mk4 at high high levels because if you want a really good calcium in the bone
You have to use mk4
Not mk7 which is good to get to absorb calcium in absorbed vitamin D
At mk4 is the only thing that will give calcium into the bone
And if you have bone loss whether it's osteoporosis osteopedia or a metastatic cancer to the bone
With lidic lesions and bone loss you have to use mk4 at very high doses
And that osteo-k is the literally the only product of the market that has the dose level that you need
That's super expensive or anything but osteo-k we have a number of people on
Next question. I'm wondering if you might be familiar with total triadols said to be vitamin E's cousin
Good for lower cholesterol and triglycerides if so would it be good
For a breast cancer hormone positive patients
So
Polkotriadols are not vitamin E's cousin
Well, I actually pulled up a little bit before I saw this question
So
I understand
vitamin E in nature
has
Really eight parts to it. It has the outer to cough or all
rings
And this is the this is the organic cup of
Makeup of a total triadol and to cough or all
So vitamin E was like so many of the supplements so so many of the vitamins when they were first discovered
There was only
There was only a certain level of
Bicroscopy so they could only see so much of the nutrient
So the guy who discovered vitamin C
Discovered the to cough or all so he called vitamin C to cough or all and then notice there were other to cough or all rings
Actually four of them
So that's the why they're named alpha beta
Gamma delta to cough or there's four to cough or all rings
So legally you could
By vitamin E you could go down to walmart and by vitamin E and it will say alpha to cough or alpha beta to cough or mixed to cough or
Okay, that's all legally a vitamin E
But that's not really what vitamin E is in nature
So if you eat food with vitamin E I'll say you eat some salmon with vitamin E in it
You're not getting just the to cough or all rings
So later when with microscopy as improved
But the patent done vitamin E already came out the patent the definition of vitamin E already came out as having these four to cough or all rings
So legally you could sell alpha to cough or all in the store and you could call it vitamin E legally
But really that's not really true. So there's a lot of not truths in vitamins
So vitamin E later discover that it actually has an inner component
Inside the to cough or all rings and there's four components and those and those are the total triadols
So there's alpha beta gamma and delta total triadol
So you have these eight components of vitamin D
Well, then they've been they've been studied individually
So alpha the to cough or all's can be very beneficial for breast cancer
There's studies on that outer to cough or all's for breast cancer and they've shown a cough or all's
It's a cough or all's a total triadol in high dose actually are pro oxidative and they can help kill cancers of all kinds
But many of the studies were done in breast cancer and the shy dose to cough or all's have shown to help with breast cancer
I'm convinced that it's really any of the it's if you did the whole food vitamin it would be a high dose all the to cough or all the total triadols
Now the delta total triadol that's the inner part delta total triadol
Is has been shown to be extremely beneficial for protection of cardiovascular disease
It's been extremely beneficial to show healing
um endothelial cells that remember endothelial cells are the epithelial cells that line our
Vascular system those both are arteries at our beta systems are lined by a single layer of
epithelial cells called your endothelial layer
So those can be easily damaged those that endothelial air can be easily damaged by high cold or cysteine by heavy metals by
H pylori we've talked about that before
By toxins in our environment and that could lead to etchied and cholesterol build up
Clestrols not the bad guy remember. It's the damage to the artery and cholesterol is actually trying to hatch that damaged endothelial
so
So also
toxins get underneath the endothelial layer and can damage the smooth muscle layer which has a lot of
um
receptors in it ACE2 receptors and etc. that
um are affected by nitric oxide synthase we've had discussions about nitric oxide synthase
There's actually a nitric oxide synthase that's called endothelial nitric nitric oxide synthase or it'll s3
That acts on smooth muscles to help decrease blood pressure and when you have damage to those receptors
You can end up with a decrease in nitric oxide synthase and high blood pressure and the delta-tocoltrinal can help heal that
So the delta-tocoltrinal has been studied widely in helping with cardiovascular events. There are a lot of other things too
um at at a correct dosage which is a relatively
high dosage
Vitamin E either the iat like to use the torque referrals and the tocoltrinal mix that's what our apoc E is
So our apoc E is tocoltrinal and tocoltrinal especially the delta fraction of the tocoltrinal
Because it is so good for cancer to help kill cancer cells for ask cancer regardless of what type of cancer it is
And it's so protective of the endothelial layer and remember are the cardiovascular disease is still the number one cause of death in the United
States we don't want you surviving cancer the dropping dead of a heart attack. So taking the apop B is very beneficial
um it's beneficial for anyone in the dosage of taking one to three of those a day is very beneficial
So that's the story. It's really not the the it's not the
Pleasant of vitamin E
Pococ Tocoltrinal are the inner part of the whole food vitamin E molecule in the nature
Though it's off. That's why I don't like so many over the counter supplements that you would buy in Walbard
Because they're going to give you the cheapest form of vitamin E by legally collated vitamin E and they're only going to give you the alpha tocoltrinal
Which really in high dose can be beneficial for
Uh, uh, cancer
But it's more beneficial for the skin. It does nothing for cardiovascular tocoltrinal do nothing for the cardiovascular system
Benefact sadly
I don't know I spent too much time on this but sadly they did a study a number years ago. This is about 10 12 years ago
To try to disprove the benefits of vitamin E with cardiovascular issues
Um, now they don't necessarily do these studies bashing supplements anymore because so many of the drug companies have bought out the supplement companies
Sorry, but very cynical, but that's exactly the truth. So um, so now they
Don't necessarily do these studies, but they purposely did this study on whether vitamin E would be beneficial for heart disease
And they used the
Uh, uh, tocoltrinal the alpha tocoltrinal and they said it was actually it was actually detrimental to the heart
People just taking high-dose tocoltrols had more heart issues
And then people that were taking it. Well, the problem is is that if you take a fractional supplement like just taking it to
You're gonna actually if you're gonna have more in your gut and you're gonna take up absorption sites
Then if you were eating good food with the whole food vitamin E with the delta tocoltrinal that are so supportive to the heart
You're actually taking up absorption sites
That you're not absorbing all the vitamin E from your food
So people that were on this study that were taking high-dose alpha tocoltrinal were actually
blocking absorption of the delta fraction of the tocoltrinal so they weren't getting that protective benefit from the tocoltrinal's from their diet
So it was actually hurting their heart
Well, they purposely did this and they got called out of this on this study
But of course it went out on CNN and you know all the new stations that take advantage is actually bad for your heart
It's totally flawed study. This is how the real companies have worked in the games that they played for years
Well, now they don't necessarily push those studies so much because they bought out
You know all these you know
medigenics and even good supplement companies are now owned by drug companies. So now they're
friendly to
nutrition or say but
That's the scam that we have had to deal with
My wife some such as like
Okay, next question
I would like to increase my understanding of the right machine does the light work through pajamas and clothing
Well
Yes, it does go through your pajamas. You don't need a skin to skin contact but any any barrier
It's going to cut down. It's effectiveness now going through a piece of cotton fabric is not going to cut down the better book
Now I've had people where they detoxed too harshly with the right
They they felt like it was just kind of blowing them away the night program and I had to put the ball under the bed for a period of time until they
dealt with that in the link and put the ball back in
Bed with them. Well now you're going through a mattress. It's definitely
can be you know, it can
it can
cut down on the
amplitude of frequencies that you're getting so
But going through the jambas and clothing though you're fine. Now remember if you want to understand the right machine better
You have access to the frequency course
So the frequency course I probably have over 300 different videos
I answer in every question of the right machine that you could think of that or about saying
Can't answer you go ahead and ask the same questions I don't care on this zoom call
So you can get your answers
But if you really do want to dig into the benefits of the right machine go to the course and
And listen to some of the videos
Um, and then if that sparks questions feel free to ask them
next question
But I spoke with you a week or two ago about addressing parasites you recommended the product here at Cleve
The instructions of the bottle say to take two capsules once a day after meals
For someone who's loaded with parasites who would it be helpful to take twice a day that a motor would have be harmful
Also how many hours should I be using the right parasite frequencies daily
For the one all clear is three hours long
Um, so the parasite on the program first of all you do it as often as you can
So I know you don't want to be sitting there doing a program
And taking up six hours of your day
That you could be doing other things
But so you just have to use balance and if you're gonna sit and watch a movie you're gonna sit and read a book then by all means run a program
Um, you can't run to you can't do it too often because the answer
As far as how you should take the paracler I've had people with loaded with parasites
That I've had to take that took 12 or more a day for a short period of time
But every day for you know 12 to 15 a day for three months
But they were taken 12 to 15 a day for a week or two
To help knock this down and they dropped out to four six a day
Two a day I don't think is gonna do it. Don't so I thought I emailed you with dosage
I thought I said four to six a day or something like that. I can't remember
But yeah, no, I've never recommended paracleric just the dosage of the bottle the dosage of the bottle is just for
You know
Not necessarily for trying to kill parasites, but trying to maintain
Is radii's rice a good supplement for someone with high cholesterol instead of a prescription drug or do you recommend something else
I know this is not cancer related. So I understand if you'd rather not address it
And what point would you say the right is not working for someone with cancer and would you recommend
And what would you recommend instead frequency wise? I should assume those two questions
Into two different slides, but
Red yeast rice can a person use that for high cholesterol. Yes, you can
One of the things could you use up for high cholesterol?
Bergamit works good for high cholesterol burmarine even works for high cholesterol
But yes, red yeast rice is something that some people have tried it and it works well
For high cholesterol and some people have tried it said that it doesn't work and they use Bergamit or a combination of different things
And what works best for them they have to kind of trial and error
Now we do have to define what high cholesterol is too
So if a person's would I treat someone what I treat
Would I recommend a supplement for someone when
What level of cholesterol do I have to get to to to recommend a supplement for that cholesterol?
Now typically you have to ask the question why so if I
Do a blood test and my cholesterol is 256 per day, okay?
Would I recommend a supplement for that?
No, I wouldn't
Is that high cholesterol? Well again, it depends on the person so always
When you're looking at blood work, you're looking at trends. Let's say this person
Or their whole life they had cholesterol of 160 and now their cholesterol is 256
Then I would say yes, that's high cholesterol for that person
But again, so would you just use red yeast from a red rice yeast or would you use Bergamit or no you get you asked the question
Why so why does the purg why do I have my cholesterol is my liver irritated is my liver congested from some reason
So is do I have arterial dysfunction?
So remember what are the things that will increase the person's cholesterol while a poor diet? Well, that really
I mean indirectly a poor diet. Well, I eat too many things with cholesterol. That's what my doctor said
No, that's not what you're getting clustered
So even if you ate bacon every day because there are a lot of cholesterol or whatever that's not going to give you a high cholesterol
Now if you eat a lot of toxins and chemicals
That could give you a high cholesterol
Even if the toxins clinical stone-emity cholesterol in it, how would that happen?
Well, you need toxins and chemicals are going to
congest your liver
And when you have a congested liver you're going to make more cholesterol to help lubricate your liver cholesterol in fact
And making more cholesterol to help cleanse your liver could be one reason why a person has high cholesterol
So you're asking the question why is it because
By liver is toxic could be toxic from liver flux too, which is a parasite
I've had people do care parasite cleanse and their cholesterol goes down because they had liver flux
Second reason why a person has high cholesterol is that they have high homocysteine levels
Or they have high inflammation, which damage their endothelial air which we discussed before remember the endothelial air is the single
layer of epithelial cells that bind with vessels
If there's damage to those
Cells damage to the endothelial air your body will make more cholesterol because the purpose of cholesterol one purpose
cholesterol is to
lack the arteries to
to to break to
patch that damage
So that could be a reason so you have to address the reason why we're just going to
Take a drug or take a supplement to reduce cholesterol and not address why cholesterol is high
Then we could leave the patient to the worst situation
Now the better thing to do is to do you know multiple things at the same time treat the reason why and try to lower cholesterol
If that be the case now typically cholesterol
You know
25270 280 and my book still isn't high unless again that patient had a trend that was much lower
You know a year ago, and now it's the jump to weigh up
When I graduated from school cholesterol normal cholesterol was 250
So 250 and below now they keep lowering it why because they have statin drugs that they can prescribe and make a bloody fortune on
And so they have to lower the the normal so that they can get more people on the drug
Well, that's a cynical thing to say Dr. Cutters you're just being mean to these drug companies
I'm sorry, but the truth sometimes is greater is crazier than fiction because that's actually the truth
That being said you want to look for the reason why always
um, and that just treat the value the blood failure
So again, okay, we could take a stat drug and your cholesterol goes back to normal
Did you fix the reason why the cholesterol was high? I mean to me no doubt at all
So I mean we might as well have just you know crossed out that value on your blood test
Oh 350 that's too high. Let's just scribble that out. Let's just write in 220 to 20 okay there
Still then fix the problem doing that either
So what difference does it make if you artificially lower a blood value if you artificially change a blood value
With the drug without treating the reason why the blood value was there
It's just it's just as beneficial as you scratching out the number and writing it whatever number you want. Oh there. No imperfect
That's very silly, but it is true. So think of that so always digging to the reason why
This is other question is a separate question. So let's dress it and what point would you say that right?
There's not working for someone with cancer and would you recommend something else instead frequency lines
Okay, so if the person's cancer is continuing to grow and you have that everything you possibly can with
right technology and you've done everything you possibly can
um
With nutrition and changing nutrition. Now my promise to you is not
To anybody's not that I could make person's cancer go away, but my promise is always that I'll never stop trying
So
We need to tweak things so you need to constantly be tweaking things now do you ever suggest other frequency devices maybe is the question
Absolutely, there's other frequency devices that can help too pdf can help. There's other different therapy devices that can help with cancer
There's other different therapy metabolic therapies like you know IV therapies and things that can help with cancer. So the current person's cancer
Is continuing to progress then you know the worst thing that you can do in my book is to not communicate with me so that you're
I've never gonna shame you or never gonna think that oh, it's your fault or it's my fault
You know, it is what it is. We just have to be a realist and we need to tweak things and if I'm not the person who can
Apply change and we'll find somebody else that can apply change
My purpose is only to help you so if a cancer is progressing
With everything that we are doing then we have to do something different or seek for something different
I will give advice where best and that's where sometimes I tell people we need to do chemo or we need to do radiation or we need to do whatever
So
Absolutely, just be open with me and never think you're
If fed deeply in anyone
Next question. I have a supplement
Called RepairBite from apex heterogenics very familiar with that supplement. I don't mean it could
Repair by hurting stomach, but it's made ingredient is El glutamine
You have another suggestion
To maybe achieve my goal since I think you said no glutamine for cancer patients. Yeah, you can't take that
So RepairBite most of your
gap repair supplements on the market are going to have El glutamine
Well, why? Well, El glutamine is
Is fuel for growth of
Epithelial cells and many cancers are
Epithelial in origin and if you take El glutamine you are just basically throwing it
Gasoline on a fire for cancer growth. So you don't want to take El glutamine in a supplement form
No, you know, let's say if your cancer is stable. Let's say your cancer is doing well
My cancer is really stable. I feel like I'm in a state of revision
And I take a repair by for three weeks to help heal my gut. Well, yes, you can
So, but if my cancer is not stable, it is growing
But I have this serious gut problem, too. Then you don't want to use glutamine at all. No
So there's other supplements. I mean, just look at the back of RepairBite
There's it's got slippery El and it's got
The different things that will help heal the gut
Um, oh
We use the product with cancer patient called GI sued, which is a lossage that you put in your mouth from zymogen
It's a great product to help heal the gut
Um, um, it doesn't have nearly as many things as it as RepairBite does
But it it so it might take a little longer, but it has decosterized licorice
It has slippery El that has something else that I can't take off my head
But it does not have glutamine
So um, but you may have other products in your cabinet at home that have
That if you look at the back of RepairBite, you might have some of those in singular products
That don't have glutamated, so that's what you want to look for
Okay, the first question from Richette
Would chemtrail right program be a good option to run if I have been exposed to chemicals and natural gas
Yes, you could do that you that would be fine
Now somebody asked last week, you know, what's a good right program to help with detoxification
And I want to clarify my answer a little bit
So are there frequencies that can help with detoxification? Well
I think there's a lot of misunderstanding around detoxification in the alternative worlds
So um, lots of people think I just need to do in details. I mean, that's what I need to do
Just talk to somebody say I just think I need to do a detail so it would be a good detail
The truth is you you understand the metabolic pathways
So you got to think like a physiologist
So from a physiological standpoint your body is always detoxifying
Your liver is grabbing things out of the blood. It's filtering the blood
So I need it through what are called phase one phase two and phase three pathway
And then
Binding it to bio that's phase three
And then bio goes into the bio duct ultimately down to the gall bladder and dumps into the small intestine
And you hopefully don't reabsorb it. That's the beneficial benefit of binders
And once it's in the intestines, hopefully you're deposited into the toilet next
That's how you get toxins out of your body
Now can frequencies help that?
Um
Yes, and no so um, can frequencies help the liver
Can function better? Yes, so there's liver support programs that might be the best thing
So um, so the with it I I personally did not write
I personally did not create all the programs on if you have a true right
But with the atelier Robin, I personally created all those programs
I don't think I have a chemtrail program with the atelier Robin if I do
It's all liver frequencies. I can't remember because I wrote like 1800 programs
Um, it's liver frequencies. There's no such thing as a frequency that's going to grab on to chemtrail
chemicals which first of all they've never been disclosed probably so nobody knows what they are
And grab on to them and push them out of your body, which is a work that way
So don't to understand everything
Functions in your body physiologically a different metabolic pathways
So um
Uh, that's chemistry and it's and it's controlled by neurology so you have to understand that
So do frequencies help with detoxification?
Yes, it don't so frequencies can help the liver work better if you're running
liver frequencies that could help rain
More balanced to the liver it helped the liver cells that parasites actually function better
But they're not necessarily going to directly speed up detoxification
um or
created detoxification
You know
Accelerated in any way and so people think I need to do a detox. They're in there
That's what they're saying
But I think what they're thinking is I need to
Be able to detoxify
Because I feel toxic. Well then you have to support
All those seven phases of detoxification. That's why I wrote that book and that's why I created that force
Because I think there's so much misunderstanding about what detoxification is
It's run by different genes. It's run by different metabolic pathways. It's all chemistry
With under the control of neurology
So if you really want to help with detoxification
You use different nutrients that can help support chemistry
and you use um
different therapies that can
Help with those seven phases where even like a hot pack of castor oil pack
Over your liver can help decrease the viscosity of via bio thereby allowing the flow of bio to be
To be sped up and thereby allowing
Phase one and phase two to increase
Because phase three isn't blockied it
And so that's a very physical thing you can do to help with detoxification
Coffee end of us. How did they work with detoxification coffee end of us stimulate the vagal nerve cranial nerve head
Which is the neurology behind the liver function
So the liver is controlled by vagus nerve. So if you stimulate the vagus nerve you're going to help stimulate
The phase one phase two pathways in the liver
But again, if you're not if your gallbladder is all stuffed up and you're not getting good bio flow
You're not helping things or if you're if your gut is so damaged because you continue to eat graph foods
You're still absorbing stuff that you get your liver work so hard to get rid of and dump into the small intestine in the first place
Or if you're constipated you're you're not having good bowel movements and emptying your balls
Then you're you're going to be reabsorbing those things. That's why
Start at phase six. Make sure you're having good bowel movements then phase five. Make sure you're binding this stuff in the colon
Then phase four. Make sure your gallbladder is functioning well and your in your bile flow is is
You know is moving slow as as smoothly as possible
Then go to phase one two three and you're supporting with copying them as a different things like that and and do
specific nutrition that I gave you
Dan Delaian root milk distill and different things like that to help support phase one two and three
And then you could move on to I'm going to use a key later that's going to grab on this stuff in the tissues to help
Pull it into the blood to get it into the liver to get it into the small intestine to get into the large intestine to get into the toilet
so
When somebody says what rife program should I use for detox
Really maybe liver programs, but really
That's not that would not be my first go too
Again, it's like any tool. Okay, I'm mr. rife fan right because I'm probably the most renowned person in the world on rife
Technology as far as clinical use because I've been doing this for so long, but again
You don't use a hammer to put in the screw
It will work maybe
But you use a screwdriver that use the best tool possible
So rife for detox is that going to help? Yeah, it's going to help but indirectly you're using rife to kill cancer to kill pathogens
Estimulate cell function to stimulate cell
um health and bring back residents to cells so it can help indirectly by helping the liver
It's not specifically going to pull stuff out of your body
So yeah, sorry long question
Next question my liver numbers
A L T A S T and one with a really long name alkaline phosphatase probably are all going
Do you think if I back off on the fed bed and I've erected it will go down or should I back off on some of the supplements
So if the only change is bed taking bed is all I've erected and supplements again
It's the fed bed resolve that's causing it. It's not the hypervector most likely. It's certainly not the supplements
So remember one of the side effect of doing
bed dissolve is that many people
Probably 50% of the population don't detoxify it well
That's kind of the going rate with my patients
50% of the people don't detoxify fed bed is all real well
And they have to keep an eye on their liver markers
They're A L T A S T and alkaline phosphatase if you do that by running a comprehensive metabolic panel
So that will include those numbers at Billy room and some other things that you want to look at
But if A L T A S T and and alkaline phosphatase is going up your liver is
um
stressed
so
Pretty much guarantee it's the fed bed is all now
I've had people that are doing
Something else some other drug like chemo or something at the same time
Then it's hard to discern because chemo therapy can certainly do that
The fed bed is all has been a common culprit
So I would just back off on the fed bed is all you could probably still take the hypervector and definitely you could take some of this
I'm also doing ivy might even see 50,000 grams the disk drive up liver numbers. No
No, I've never seen that
So but I've seen again
And then it's all 50% of the people take it then then I will have
next question
I'm taking 30,000 I use weekly of d3 plus k but my lab shows lower than desire
43 might have indeed levels
What could I take look at that might be hindering my absorption
I am working on parasites right now anything else I could take
Well, there's I don't remember your genetics
But there are there are vitamin D receptor genes
And especially the vitamin D that I think it's the tacky gene
That hinders your absorption so if you have a single or double leal defect of that gene
There's nothing you could do you're just going to have to take more
So
It's it just is what it is
So people that have that genetic defect
Are definitely you look at their vitamin D levels if they're not taking vitamin D their vitamin D levels are usually in the pits
Um, and they have to take a lot of vitamin D now vitamin D
Interesting because people are going to probably have questions about how this person is taking their vitamin D
Why would a person take 30,000 I use a week
Um instead of taking it
You might be taking it daily you might just be listed it as a weekly dosage
So if so technically vitamin D is a fat-soluble vitamin so you could
Just take one dose per week technically
However, if you're taking one dose per week, you're only going to absorb so much
You know you have absorption sites for these nutrients you're only going to absorb so much for dose
So
Though it's because it's a fat-soluble vitamin I have said and most people have said that you couldn't take it anytime during the day and
Um, you could just take the whole dose you don't have to split it up into multiple doses
But people with the vitamin D receptor gene defect that can't their vitamin D levels up. That's a little bit different air
Um, split it up in the smaller doses throughout the day
You're going to have a better chance of absorbing because you have
You know absorption sites that are hindered because of that defect
So
Splitting it up more taking more so you're taking 10,000 I use three times a week you're probably better off taking
um, maybe 10,000 units a day
Um, maybe in a in a in a product that's maybe 5,000 I use and take one of the more even one at night
That's the way you have to play with it
I have some especially some autoimmune patients
That um have the a double effect at multiple multiple VDR genes
And they have to play with it like that and they're taking
Very high doses to be able to get through
Next question back on inflammation topic one remedy you mentioned so did to me like
Uh
Captain or cap so curfew men
So the remedy is in so you could just look if you look at our store and you look at the product clear inflam or inflammatory
Um, it has a really good balance of the flavonoids so first thing you think of with
With the inflammation is the flavonoids
So, um, I'm I'm not looking at it right now, but clear inflam has curfew men
Aswellia stiggy dental
Verceted rosemary
Probably a few other ones
Uh another good product is a batallin
Which is not in that because their company that
Makes batallin as a as a patent on it
And it is the same company that makes the aloevia immune
It's uh, it's called aloevia limitless
And that has been miraculous for some people
So, um, batallin is is there's much research on that as the most powerful anti inflammatory
Um, and uh, so that comes in a blister pack
And you the very small little capsules, but it's pure batallin
Um, that's aloevia
Limitless is the day
And that can be extremely beneficial
Taking one to three of those a day
It can be extremely beneficial to decrease inflammation
Next question for the vitamin D supplement should I be taking that with food especially fats then
Um, I don't know I don't know if
But it's a fat soluble vitamin
Beating that it it breaks down very slowly in your body
It doesn't necessarily mean that you absorb it better with fats
I I don't know if you absorb it better with fats or that I don't do it with research on that
And would the gene be listed on the genetic report?
Um, yes it would, it's the BDR gene so if you'd have to look at your big report
Um, the as a vitamin D as a D and receptor on
So that's what those genes are in the vitamin D receptor genes
Um, it's in the big report. It's way down
Two-thirds down
Probably on page three hundred or so
All right, well, it's good to have everybody on today's call
um
Wish you guys of the last week remember no zoom call next week
So no zoom call next week um
And do you guys have a great week and we'll talk to you again in two weeks